BUT FIRST, HYPE AND HYPERBOLE.
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE DEMOCRATS
DECLARED PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ON
THE ROPES?
SEEMS LIKE EVERY OTHER DAY
SELF-RIGHTEOUS ANCHORS WITH VERY
SERIOUS FACES TELL THE
FICTITIOUS WHITE HOUSE AND
CRISIS STORY.
MAKE NEWS RUNS THE GAMUT FROM
THE TRIVIAL -- THE PRESIDENT IS
ANGRY AND ISOLATED, THE STAFF IS
MISERABLE, TO BE MORE SERIOUS.
>> YOU CANNOT FIRE COMEY FOR THE
WRONG REASONS.
YOU CANNOT FIRE HIM FOR
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> THIS IS A CRISIS FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
IT'S ALWAYS THE BEGINNING OF THE
END.
REMEMBER DIRE PREDICTIONS OF DON
JR.'S MEETING AND THE RUSSIAN
LAWYER?
>> HE SHOULD BE CONCERNED EVEN
MORE SO THAN FOR HIMSELF.
IF DONALD JR. HAS SOME LEGAL
EXPOSURE HERE.
>> I THINK THEY ARE SHOCKED.
THE NEWS IS FRIGHTENING AND
PEOPLE MIGHT GO TO JAIL.
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> Laura: THE NOOSE IS
TIGHTENING!
THE FRENZY SURROUNDING THE
HINGING ON THE WORD OF HIS
FORMER ATTORNEY, MICHAEL COHEN.
>> IF THIS MICHAEL COHEN WHEN
EVIDENCE STANDS UP, IF MICHAEL
COHEN DOES STAND UP TO THIS,
THIS IS A POTENTIALLY HUGE,
POTENTIALLY SOMETHING THAT COULD
PROVE THE PRESIDENT COLLUDED,
AND THAT IS AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> Laura: GIRL, MAX HEADROOM!
WHO COULD FORGET THE GOOFBALLS
PREDICTING A STORY PEDDLED BY A
PORN STAR COULD TOPPLE TRUMP?
>> IF IT SEEMS TO BE CREDIBLE,
THAT COULD BRING DOWN THIS
PRESIDENCY.
>> >> Laura: OH, DONNIE.
THROUGHOUT ALL OF IT, THE
MEDIA'S MASSIVE HEART POUNDING
BUILDUP OF THE MUELLER PROBE.
>> WE ARE SEEING THE COLLUSION
PIECE OF THIS PIECE BY PIECE
STARTING TO BE BUILT OUT.
>> THE PRESIDENT LOOKS LIKE
SOMEBODY WHO IS INCREASINGLY
DESPERATE.
>> Laura: THE CRISIS CLICHES
NEVER STOPPED.
>> IT FEELS LIKE WE ARE FINALLY
AT A TIPPING POINT.
THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Laura: CLOSING IN!
BUT ALWAYS WRONG, NEVER IN
DOUBT.
AND NEVER A CORRECTION OR A MEA
CULPA.
THEIR GOAL FROM DAY ONE IS TO
DRIVE TRUMP OUT OF OFFICE, THE
FACTS BE DAMNED.
THE LAST 48 HOURS, THE GET TRUMP
GANG DID THEIR HYPE AND HAVE A
REALLY ALL OVER AGAIN.
FIRST IS THE NEWS OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S IG'S URGENT MEETING
WITH LAWMAKERS.
WHILE THE COYOTE IS
FINALLY GOING TO CATCH THE
LAWMAKER.
THAT MEANS SOMETHING IS IN THOSE
DOCUMENTS THAT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE PEOPLE DOING THIS
IMPEACHMENT INCREASE SEE
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Laura: IMMEDIATELY!
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
OR NOT SO MUCH.
>> I DON'T REALLY KNOW THE
RELEVANCE OF IT.
AT CERTAIN PART IT'S HARD TO
FOLLOW.
>> THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE I
THINK DIRECTLY RELEVANT TO THE
TRUMP'S IMPEACHABLE CONTACT.
>> Laura: FOILED AGAIN!
DRAFT.
AT FIRST YOU DON'T SUCCEED,
HYPE, HYPE AGAIN.
DEMOCRATS WERE SALIVATING ON AIR
AND OFF ABOUT TODAY'S TESTIMONY
BY KURT VULGAR.
THEY THOUGHT HIS RESIGNATION,
WHICH WAS FORCED, AS
SOMEHOW WOULD
BE A BLOCKBUSTER.
INSTEAD, IT WAS ANOTHER DIED.
>> HAD SAID NOTHING THAT
COINCIDES WITH WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING, WITH THEIR
WHOLE IMPEACHMENT NARRATIVE.
UNBELIEVABLY KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN UKRAINE.
>> Laura: ANSWER
MR. IMPEACHMENT ADAM SCHIFF, HE
SEEMED TODAY ODDLY QUIET.
>> WOULD YOU MIND TELLING US
ABOUT THIS?
>> Laura: HE HAS COMMENTS
ABOUT COMMENTS, YOU CAN STOP HIM
FROM TALKING!
SUDDENLY TODAY, CAT HAD ITS
TONGUE.
THIS WOULD BE SO FUNNY IF IT
WEREN'T SO SERIOUS.
DEMOCRATS DOING EQUIVALENT DAY
AFTER DAY YELLING FIRE IN A
CROWDED THEATER.
AND THAT THEATER IS AMERICA.
THIS IS DOING ENORMOUS DAMAGE TO
THE COUNTRY.
AND AS FOR THE PRESS, THEY LOST
THEIR CREDIBILITY A LONG TIME
AGO.
NOT SURE THEY CAN GO ANY LOWER,
BUT THEY ARE TRYING.
ALL THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO DO